hey youtubers it's Charlie thank you
everybody that left questions on my Game
of Thrones video this weekend everybody
likes hearing about the Tyrells and I
did try to include a couple questions
about the knight of flowers everyone
everyone's still kind of thinking about
what's going on as of the end of season
five and don't forget this weekend
actually Khaleesi terminator is on the
big screen lots of things happening with
Game of Thrones people in the next two
weeks so I also have Comic Con news at
the end of this so here we go
just careful for spoilers if you're not
caught up on season 5 so here we go John
shark asks do you think that tormund
will lead the wildlings against the
mutiny crows as well as the White
Walkers
I hope torment kills Alliser thorne this
time yeah yeah I don't think that
they're just gonna be sitting around for
all of season 6 they're down in the gift
right now remember that was part of the
promise that Jon Snow made to them that
they would get the gift in exchange for
coming down the wildlings themselves
aren't like super best friends with Jon
Snow or anything like that but the
Nights Watch hates the wildlings the
ones that mutant need that was the whole
reason for them killing Jon Snow
so there's like a 99% chance that
there's gonna be something going on
between the crows and the wildlings the
real question is is are they going to be
able to find some sort of common ground
because if the White Walkers come and
they're still fighting each other then
it's gonna be really bad for everyone
next question akaash asks I'm currently
reading dancer dragons and I just read
the first Melisandre POV chapter and in
the vision instead of seeing Stannis
like she wants to she says I asked him
to show me his aura high and all he
shows me is snow do you think that this
is hinting that jon is going to be a
Zora hi no not necessarily I think that
it just indicates that he is a person of
interest to the Lord of Light they did a
good job at the end of season 5 and in
telling us that Melisandre isn't always
a hundred percent on her game she was so
confident that Stannis was going to be
the champion of the red God but in the
last episode you see that look of horror
on her face as the blood drains out like
she's realizing oh my god I was wrong
about this so don't ever take mellow
Sandra's visions as being super literal
all I think it means is is that he is a
very important character it doesn't mean
whether he's important bad or important
good there's a lot of competing theories
that he could be co-opted by the night's
king the White Walkers or he could be
co-opted by Melisandre in the red God
right now everything is still widely
open to interpretation so if you have a
theory that involves Jon Snow being
important it's at least a little bit
right no matter what you think next
question why it asks what will happen to
the storm Lance now that house Baratheon
is essentially dead
well the crown would probably just
appoint someone else caretaker like that
they would give it to someone else and
when I say the crown I'm really talking
about Kevan Lannister because he's the
one calling the shots in the small
council right now he came back to King's
Landing was Sir she got her ass thrown
in jail so he is like the new Tywin in
King's Landing although he is no Tywin
just in terms of personalities I think
they're cut from the same cloth but
kevin is a little bit softer to the
Tywin he's not quite as hardcore here's
a crazy thought he's not first in line
but remember Jaime promised Bronn a
bigger caste a much bigger castle if he
came down and rescued Myrcella with him
it looks like Michelle is dead but you
know if some other big need were to
arise the crown could promise storm's
end to Bronn the other lords would
probably get super pissed about it like
I don't think anybody in the small
council any of the other aristocracy in
Westeros would go for it they they'd be
super pissed because storm's end is huge
but it's always possible they could
offer that as a reward to broad for
doing something else really really crazy
like bring me the head of Tyrion
Lannister and I will give you storms end
realistically speaking though the crown
will probably just appoint a temporary
caretaker next question
tech asks will there be an Aegon's
conquest spin-off series or any
spin-offs in Game of Thrones well I
think HBO is gonna try and do everything
it can to keep Game of Thrones on HBO
beyond the main series so I would say
yes to spin-off but it's up in the air
as to what it could be a gods conquest
would definitely be very interesting but
I think HBO would go with something a
little bit more familiar typically when
networks do spin-offs they use familiar
characters and like the closest thing we
have to characters that we haven't seen
but that we've heard about on the show
or people from Robert's rebellion like
Lyanna Stark Rhaegar Targaryen
if HBO wanted to lay the safest possible
bet for a spin-off series that's
probably what they would do if they
wanted to get really high concept with
it that they would do something from the
distant past like dunk an egg or Aegon's
conquest or even ancient Valyria that
would probably involve a lot of CG
dragon
anything requiring heavy special-effects
was pretty low on their list Robert's
rebellion would look almost exactly like
Game of Thrones does right now and I
think HBO likes that idea it just means
they wouldnt have to pay tens of
millions of dollars for really different
costumes really different locations they
could shoot a lot of the same places and
just redress them a little bit plus you
have the added action of a major
conflict like like a major shitstorm and
those tend to be very exciting to watch
on screen the problem is is that if they
did something more with Game of Thrones
they would probably still want to
maintain some of the really amazing WTF
stuff like White Walkers and we just we
didn't see a whole lot of White Walkers
during Robert's rebellion like they had
just started to resurface at the end of
that so they're gonna be issues note no
matter what they choose but I think you
know Robert's rebellion is the safe bet
but something cooler would be Duncan egg
next question
middle Ian desks who do you think can
restore peace and control in the north
now that Stannis is dead and the Starks
are lost well I think the Bolton's are
really in charge of keeping the north
under control although Littlefinger is
trying to move in on that Littlefinger
doesn't strike me as the type to bring
peace so I think for most of season 6
Roose Bolton is gonna try and do it but
the north will remember in super
hardcore ways like seriously they're
casting a bunch of people for northern
storylines so if anything season 6 up in
the north is gonna look a lot more like
it did during the war of the five kings
the North making war against Roose
Bolton and thinning out his ranks his
army is still pretty big like whenever
he fought Stannis is into the season it
looked like he had a massive army so
maybe the north will be culling that
through the course of season six next
question SJ Burks asks can you talk
about the differences between the knight
of flowers on the show versus the books
were you talking about Loras he's called
the knight of flowers because of his
personal coat of arms it's just a
variation on the traditional house
Tyrell coat of arms he has three golden
flowers on a field of green it's just
meant to honor his own personal tastes
and his position as third son really the
biggest change and it's actually a
pretty big one is that in the books
Loras is part of Joffrey's Kingsguard he
spends a lot more time in proximity to
Jaime so Jaime thinks about him and in
his POV chapters on the
you really don't get a sense for his
character as much as you do in the books
Jamie thinks of him as not being false
meaning like he's not a complete liar
but he hasn't proven himself as a true
knight yet but for the most part the
show has hit a lot of like the really
big stuff he was part of Renly's rainbow
knights during the war of the five kings
but what the show is done his tried to
marry him to Cersei so that that's why
he's not in the Kingsguard because
Kingsguard can't marry and even before
he was supposed to marry Cersei he was
supposed to marry Sansa so he couldn't
be in the Kingsguard then either so I
think that's why the show made that
change next question
mercury wolf asks why are the Lannisters
so evil why do they believe themselves
better than anyone else well I mean
that's a matter of perspective I
wouldn't call them evil I would just say
most of them are very determined Cersei
is the closest thing you could call to
being a cruel Lannister and when you
think about it from Circe's perspective
I mean I mean the show doesn't do POV
chapters so you don't get a sense for
this but in the books
Cersei just feels very undermined like
she feels growing up a woman there were
a lot of opportunities that weren't
given to her just because Westeros is
such a patriarchy she even jokes that as
children because Jaime and Cersei were
twins they would actually switch clothes
Jaime would dress up in her little girls
clothing and she would dress up in his
armor and they would walk around the
castle to see if anybody noticed and
usually nobody would notice so she
thinks to herself you know had I grown
up a man I wouldn't be having all these
problems that I'm having right now we
have no idea what would happen had she
actually been born a man but if you
really look at it she kind of is the son
that Tywin always wanted she wants power
the problem is is that her circumstances
have led her to make some very
questionable choices in this past season
so I think you could argue either way
you know like even if she had been born
a man maybe she'd still be just as nuts
as she is right now so the Lannisters
aren't so much evil as they are morally
grey the closest thing to an evil person
on the show you know just in terms of
the Great Houses right now would be
Roose Bolton just we watch that scene
Brady tells Ramsay about his mother and
tell me that Roose Bolton is not evil
next question you and I asks is the
nares going to free her other dragons
someday well I would say while mother's
away the Dragons will play so your wall
Tyrion is watching Marine don't expect
everything to go completely smoothly
with
Dragons somebody still has to feed him
while she's gone I don't know whether or
not they'll get out or how soon but I
think that they're just a bomb waiting
to go off they're kind of like the wild
Lynx sitting down in the gift they're
not just gonna sit around for an entire
season and do nothing we can only hope
that they'll just they'll make some
really spectacular mess and it'll be
amazing to watch on-screen next question
cat asks what's gonna happen to mace
Tyrell and Braavos is he going to die
there well you know I think you know if
you're talking about this stuff going on
with Arya I think the whole reason for
all that Bravo stuff with mace was
really to get Meryn Trant they're like
that's that's why the writers wrote it
that way they resolved that storyline in
the season finale Meryn Trant is gone so
I think mace Tyrell is just gonna come
back and he'll just be back in King's
Landing during season six Kevan
Lannister looks like he's fixed the
small council and they need their master
of coin and that's what mace Tyrell is
so they need him back in King's Landing
next question and madelyn asks where's
Dolores Edie
we know he survived Hart home in the
boat with John why wasn't he with John
at the season finale well I mean it was
like the end of the night so he was
probably asleep they'll address that in
episode 1 you have to remember they
ended on a cliffhanger so they have to
tell us what happens in the moments
after that someone has to find his body
everyone has to go nuts because those
people that killed John that wasn't the
entire Nights Watch that was really only
about half of them so don't worry we'll
find out what Dolores ed is gonna do
we'll find out where it ghost is like
he'll price show up again seriously
that's an even bigger question where was
ghost in the season finale what was he
doing
he was probably off hunting but if
drogon can sense the Daenerys is in
trouble and come to her aid then why
didn't ghost do that he must have just
found like the biggest tastiest rabbit
ever next question John asks how the
hell is she gonna face the White Walkers
without dragonglass she's screwed what
defense do White Walkers have against
dragons well it sounds like you kind of
answered your own question a little bit
she has dragons so she doesn't need
dragon glass as much as for White
Walkers fighting dragons I would think
that they would just use projectiles
they have the special Spears made of
enchanted ice so they'd probably just
find a way to use those as projectiles
against dragons they were flying around
just like White Walkers would be weak
against dragons dragons would be weak
against White Walkers one of the really
good things about Game of Thrones is
that no one is like supremely over
even though it seems like Daenerys is
overpowered with her dragons the
workaround to that is is the Dragons
just can't be completely controlled it's
like raising a lion you can teach it to
do tricks but it still might end up
biting you because it's instinct is
genetic like it will always be stronger
than what you program it to do so thank
you so much everyone for so many
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do what's gonna happen next is I'll
post my Arthur Dayne video and then I'll
do a Comic Con preview after that just
kind of explain what's gonna be going on
with the Game of Thrones panel what my
schedule is gonna be like the videos
I'll be doing that week really I just
want to couch your expectations for that
Game of Thrones panel they don't really
give any good information away about the
next season they usually show a blooper
reel in a casting video but because
comic-con is so early this year it's
totally possible that they won't have
that casting video it'd be a big
disappointment so I'm hoping they bring
it Maisie Williams did tease the
faceless men last year but we kind of
knew that was gonna happen already so it
wasn't a big revelation you can't even
consider it spoilery for those asking
about meetups there will be a comic-con
Meetup I just I don't know exactly when
it's gonna be I'm still finalizing my
schedule it'll probably be sometime
Friday or Saturday so there will be some
point during the weekend when you can
come you know give me a high five and
say hello which actually reminds me
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner and Naveen Kumar you win a $20
Amazon gift card just be sure to private
message me on my channel so I can get
your contact info and if you guys didn't
see I posted a Guardians video yesterday
I meant to start a new Marvel giveaway
in that so if you want under the Marvel
giveaway for this week just go leave a
comment on that Guardians video you can
click here for that and you can click
here to learn all about resurrection in
A Song of Ice and Fire
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you